[Music]
on this thursday night grocery price is
taking a bigger bite out of your wallet
how much food costs are expected to rise
next year it's going to be rough for
everybody and what's fueling the
inflation
getting answers faster the push to make
rapid covet tests more widely available
more than a half a million surgeries
postponed by the pandemic the orthopedic
surgeon i talked to said well you'd be
three to four years where some patients
are turning for their procedures
plus what's barged into vancouver it's
like a friendly new neighbor the
fascination and fondness for this washed
up
wreck global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the rising cost of
living in this country food is predicted
to get even more expensive in 2022
canada's food price report predicts
prices will rise by up to seven percent
next year that will push up the cost of
feeding the average family of four to
almost fifteen thousand dollars a year
an increase of nearly one thousand
dollars from 2021 and that estimate is
based solely on the cost of groceries it
doesn't include restaurant meals it's
partly a sign of the times the pandemic
has disrupted work and created supply
chain problems we'll have more on that
in just a moment our coverage begins
with ross lord and a look at what's
going up and how it will impact your
family
as the pandemic stretches on weary
canadians face a new challenge keeping
up with the escalating price of food
canada's annual food price report
predicts record high increases for 2022.
it's going to be rough for everybody and
he's a senior
it's uh
you know we don't get that
oh we get a cpp in old age there isn't
too much to
live on you know the projected increases
are hard to swallow meat up between zero
and two percent
bakery products between five and seven
percent and dairy up to eight percent
more expensive
everyday staples that most canadians
already find expensive
so 2022 is really going to be a tough
year for uh people in the middle class
and obviously families with less means
as well
food prices were already up by more than
four percent this year with meat leading
the way offsetting the additional
increases means finding smarter ways to
shop you have to really know your prices
and shop around buying frozen vegetables
as opposed to fresh vegetables or you
know price shopping or price comparison
using flyers or coupons it seems
bargain-hungry canadians are already
flocking to digital flyers as food
prices rise on like your your high
consumable items like milk eggs butter
bread everything
we see an increase in search activity in
general but very specifically on those
high consumable items with food banks
already overburdened since the pandemic
started food researchers say the federal
government should step up by helping
ensure supply chain industries like
trucking have the staffing to get food
products to market in time
easing at least one inflation irritant
ross lord global news halifax
to help understand what's driving up the
cost of food and groceries our senior
business correspondent and gaviola is
with me and what are some of the factors
contributing to this
there's a whole confluence of factors
coming together to push up the price of
food people have already likely noticed
it and there's more of it in the mail so
let's start things off with a look at
the key drivers including higher
transportation costs higher energy costs
feeding into all of that we also have
supply chain issues these are pretty
epic uh the likes of which we haven't
seen certainly in my lifetime we heard
from the deputy governor of the bank of
canada saying it's tricky to pinpoint
when these issues are going to be sorted
out exactly we also have labor shortages
this is a global phenomenon and it's
also something that we're seeing right
across the country and that's impacting
prices that you pay for food at the
grocery store as well as menu items and
restaurants and then a kind of fourth
final key factor donna would be climate
change and this is something that's
affecting food producers they're dealing
with more frequent severe weather events
and that's the kind of thing that's
really tough to manage so many factors
and there are ways to manage inflation
but i guess they come at a cost
right and especially when you're talking
about monetary policy this is of course
the bank of canada's number one job is
to manage inflation the bank of canada
is comfortable keeping it in a range
between one and three percent and what
we've seen certainly uh this fall is
that inflation has been running much
hotter than that for many months in a
row and under normal circumstances this
would be the green light for the bank of
canada to go ahead and raise rates right
now these are kind of uncertain times
the recovery is taking shape but it's
looking kind of uneven so the bank of
canada has telegraphed that we could see
rate hikes starting as early as spring
or summer of next year and it's
important to note those rate hikes the
goal is to kind of tame inflation and
they may have a more immediate impact on
any debt that you're carrying but when
it comes to targeting and bringing down
things like food inflation well that
could take many more months
okay and gaviola in toronto thanks
now to covert 19 in canada's two biggest
provinces the number of new cases is on
the rise ahead of the winter holidays in
ontario more than 1200 new infections
were reported today that is the highest
daily caseload since may the number of
coveted patients in hospital remains
relatively stable though provincial
health experts have warned
hospitalizations are expected to climb
driven by people who are not vaccinated
quebec also reported a spike in cases
today more than 1800 new infections
there that's the highest daily total
since january the province says many of
the new infections are people who are
not vaccinated and children quebec hopes
it can help curb new cases by
distributing free rapid tests to all
preschool and elementary school students
children will be able to take the kids
home and use them if they come down with
codelike symptoms as michael couture
reports there is a growing push to make
those rapid tests more accessible right
across canada
rapid tests are a good thing
but it's late in the game for months
olivier delay has been pushing for
widespread distribution of rapid tests
for daycare and school-aged children
he's happy the quebec government is
sending each kid home with five tests
but will not have any impact on the
current outbreaks there's over 400
outbreaks in elementary school right now
with lots of community transmission yet
those tests still aren't widely
available in the community the federal
government has handed out nearly 100
million rapid tests to the provinces but
according to health canada only about 15
percent have been used uptake and
availability differ across provinces in
nova scotia the tests are more widely
accessible
our mobile units through nova scotia
health have them there if you go to get
a pcr test you can take some home with
you ontario has sent them to congregate
living settings private businesses and
areas of high transmission they're also
sending students home with five tests
during the holidays we are distributing
everything that we have and over a
million a week is a significant
deployment of rapid tests still they're
scarce elsewhere even if you want to pay
forty dollars for one at a pharmacy in
ontario there is now a rapid test finder
twitter page and the comical hashtag
free the rats to be able to free those
rapid tests from the warehouses that are
storing all these millions of
life-saving tests compare that to the uk
where anyone who wants a rapid test can
order packs of them online from the
national health service antigen tests
have an 81 percent accuracy rate still
some infectious disease experts believe
wider usage would be helpful as people
plan holiday parties a family gathering
or something like that if everyone has a
negative rapid test before they come
into the house yeah you have now added a
significant degree of safety health
minister zhaniv zuklow says he's met
with his provincial counterparts to
discuss increased supply and use of
rapid tests and he stressed they should
be free for all canadians
mike licouter global news ottawa
we are getting a clearer picture tonight
of the staggering impact of the pandemic
on canada's health care system a new
report from the canadian institute for
health information found that since the
start of the pandemic hospitals
performed about half a million fewer
surgeries compared to previous years
that works out to on average about
thirty five thousand fewer surgeries per
month heather urix west reports on the
devastating impact of the delays and how
long it will take to clear the backlog
this happy little baby has no idea she's
running out of time one-year-old helen
dixon desperately needs eye surgery to
correct her vision because of covid that
surgery has been delayed she needs that
before her second birthday to avoid any
lifelong
issues with her vision we have no word
as to when that's going to happen yet
the pandemic has pushed back more than
half a million surgeries across the
country and not all patients have seen
the same impact over the course of the
pandemic hospital admissions for
pregnancy and delivery remained about
the same while admissions for major
cardiac diagnoses saw a bit of a drop
the largest decrease by far was for
patients needing hip and knee
replacement surgery the orthopedic
surgeon i talked to said well you'd be
three to four years
wow and i just deemed that to be
unacceptable and so tim gibson decided
to go private paying 37 000 canadian to
have his hip replacement surgery done in
montana the local provider there has
seen a huge increase in demand from
canadian patients since the pandemic
began i was just totally my numbers for
november and i've had more than 100
increase in inquiries coming in and our
surgeries um look to break the record as
well of course not everyone has the
means to pay out of pocket for timely
care to clear the backlog across the
country the canadian institute for
health information says canada's health
providers will need a plan it's not only
about money it's about the workforce
itself it's also what our population and
the population needs for graham dixon
what his daughter needs is clear he just
hopes she'll get that surgery before
it's too late
heather urex west global news calgary
in scotland people are being strongly
urged to cancel their christmas parties
because of fears of the omicron variant
public health officials there say
they've already seen a number of omicron
related outbreaks linked to christmas
parties they say early evidence shows
the variants much more transmissible and
they're asking people to defer their
parties to another time
the chinese government has a warning for
countries that have decided on a
diplomatic boycott of the beijing
olympics
a spokesperson for the chinese
government says canada australia the uk
and the us will pay the price for their
mistaken acts canada announced yesterday
that government officials will not
attend the 2022 games because of china's
human rights violations china today
dismissed the diplomatic boycott as a
farce a quebec teacher removed from the
classroom coming up why she's been
banned from teaching as parents and
students voiced support for her plus bc
sets another tragic record in the opioid
crisis
a grade 3 teacher at an anglophone
elementary school in chelsea quebec has
been removed from the classroom because
her hijab defies the province's
secularism law under the law known as
bill 21 teachers and public sector
workers are banned from wearing
religious symbols such as hijabs a
spokesperson for the western quebec
school board says it opposes the law
which was passed in 2019 but must follow
it parents of children in the teacher's
class got word of the change on friday
the children to my knowledge were not
told directly as to why
this happened and we've been kind of
grappling with our daughter and trying
to explain the situation and and why a
law like this even exists this is what
will happen and will continue to happen
to
anyone that's part of a marginalized
community in the province
supporters have been tying green ribbons
on a fence at the school in support of
the teacher and federal politicians
spoke out against the teacher's
reassignment today in ottawa
it's important that laws that are unjust
in provinces are challenged in those
provinces it sends a message clearly
that the people of quebec don't all
support this bill and see a problem with
it and the fact that it's being
challenged in court is the right thing
and it's going to continue
the teacher has been reassigned to a
role outside the classroom where bill 21
doesn't apply
the opioid crisis in bc keeps getting
worse there has been another record loss
of life from illicit drug overdoses the
bc coroner's service says a record 201
people died from a suspected drug
overdose in october that is more than
six deaths a day and so far in 2021
1782 people have died from drug toxicity
that's higher than the number of deaths
in all of 2020.
an emergency requires an urgent response
how many more deaths are we willing to
accept
before we become comfortable with the
idea of separating people
from the toxic black market
in november the province applied to the
federal government to decriminalize
personal possession of illicit drugs
bc's chief coroner is also pushing for
better access to a safe drug supply
botched border measures ahead how
canada's travel protocols fell short
during the pandemic
[Music]
the pandemic has focused attention on
canada's borders and the confusion over
the rules intended to limit the spread
of covid19 now the auditor general has
found significant gaps in the testing
and follow-up of travelers by the public
health agency of canada david aiken
joins me now with what the auditor
general discovered and why it matters
david
well donna it's the second time that
auditor general karen hogan has looked
at ottawa's border control measures and
this time she found that as recently as
june the public health agency of canada
could not confirm the health status of
tens of thousands of travelers this is
not a success story
the agency's inability to confirm
whether more than one-third of travelers
complied with quarantine orders remains
a significant problem hogan looked at
the border control measures that
affected two and a half million
travelers arriving in canada in the
12-month period ending june 30th now she
focused only on the public health agency
of canada or p hack and not on border
guards or local health officials among
her findings while nearly 13 000
travelers were told to go to quarantine
hotels
326 never showed up 71 refused to go 45
left without permission but just 13
tickets were issued but even those stats
may not be accurate because the auditor
general says p hack had no proof no
record of stay for
75 percent of those who were sent to
quarantine hotels it really is up to the
public health agency to do better at
monitoring gathering data and following
up in order to be able to demonstrate
how effective
these border measures are perhaps more
alarming the government failed to match
30 percent of the coven 19 tests it
collected with individual travelers
and where there was a positive cova 19
test p hack failed to follow up 14
percent of the time that's more than
eleven hundred individuals who tested
positive that p hack never tracked now
as quarantine hotels and on arrival
tests are back on the menu to prevent
the spread of the omicron variant the
government vows to do better mostly with
beefed up computer systems and wide
adoption of the arrive can app a good
and improving system is better than no
system at all and that's why we'll
continue to do what we need to do which
is to put into place those measures to
protect canadians in the context of the
omicron variant but as the auditor
general noted donna p hack's work to
improve those automated systems just
started last month
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks the
auditor general looked at other parts of
canada's covet 19 response including the
impact on temporary foreign workers you
can find those details on our website
globalnews.ca
global national in the u.s the
government's top road safety agency is
investigating a complaint that tesla
drivers can play video games while the
car is moving the games including
solitaire are played on the touchscreen
console the feature came in a software
update to most tesla models over the
summer a warning does pop up that only
passengers should play while a vehicle
is in motion tesla has long offered
video games on its center console but
the original version could only be
played while the car was in park the
national highway traffic safety
administration says it is in talks with
the company
i'm jordan armstrong in vancouver coming
up how a rusty old barge has become a
local celebrity that story just ahead on
global national
[Music]
[Music]
assembling ikea furniture has become a
kind of right of passage to adulthood
and if you've gone through it you know
that every item at ikea has a swedish
name well sweden has had enough
when people hear the name bolermann few
think about this beautiful lake in small
and sweden instead
most people think about this
this new tourism campaign is reclaiming
the names ikea has borrowed for
everything from toilet brushes to
garbage cans it intends to inform
travelers the words are really names of
places in sweden for example remforsa
isn't just a workbench it's actually a
small woodland village known for its
tasty mushrooms
no assembly required
well in vancouver people are flocking to
an unusual new site on the waterfront
since a big storm a few weeks ago a huge
barge has been stuck along the seawall
of one of the city's popular beaches
it's not exactly beautiful but as jordan
armstrong reports many vancouverites
have grown strangely fond of it
vancouver is known for mountains
mild winters and beautiful beaches
but one of those beaches is now occupied
by a rusty wreck
not that many are complaining who
couldn't like a barge no just because
it's an oddball you know like it's like
what are you doing here who invited you
well no one did the barge blew in
unannounced during a windstorm last
month
there was initially concern it would
crash into the burrard bridge forcing
this band's temporary closure but in the
weeks since the barge has settled in on
the rocks of the city's west end and
several attempts to move it have failed
it's like a friendly new neighbor in the
west end
we want it to stay
some are even suggesting the barge be
decorated for the holidays the wayward
vessel has spawned merchandise musings
multiple twitter accounts and on any
given day you will find people stopping
to stare i have no idea why i'm
fascinated with it but hey it's it's
something different no i guess the size
of it
thinking about where it's come from and
where it's going to go
of course any big celebrity needs a
full-time security detail and the barge
is no exception
sometimes people do crazy things like um
jump on them from the top of top of this
into the water is this the biggest star
you've protected um i think so yeah yeah
that's the biggest star i predict
but why is a city so star struck
by a barge you know a little bit
is the whole kind of selfie culture that
we live in it's it's like the perfect
kind of selfie object something fun for
a sad dreary time
and with no firm timeline for the barge
to say bon voyage
its presence will continue to make waves
jordan armstrong global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
here at canada is the christmas tree in
downtown stony plain alberta we'd love
to see your candidate especially festive
and joyful pictures this time of year
maybe barges too please email yours to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you on
saturday for the new reality take care
of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you